All right. So I have to recalibrate the amount of time it takes me to get here.
Henceforth, I'll always start promptly on time. And anybody who comes late to class will miss the best joke of the hour.
The left hand out today. And. And there's going to be more like this prepared by be prepared by our teams.
The first guinea pig was Tracy, who points to yellow. And she's given the notes that so.
So you can read this in and out here.
And this is just sort of trying to record what went on during the during the hours so that we can remember it later on.
You see, the first thing I want to show you today was a letter that I received that changed my life.
This is a I couldn't find it in my own files, although I must be there somewhere.
So I asked Bob Floyd to if he had a copy of it. He sent me this letter. It was in in the fall of 72.
And here's the here's the letter. We talked about columns in period.
He says, did they're done? Please quit using so many exclamation points.
I can't stand it. Exclamation point. Estimation point. I guess we say bang, bang.
I'm going out of my mind. Bang, bang, bang. Don't get alarmed. I'm only kidding.
Bang, bang, bang. OK, Simpson. So you know this.
This letter actually had a great effect on me.
I mean, I started looking at the art of computer programing and I had about two exclamation points per page or something like that.
It's much better. I mean, you can't. Nothing can be that surprising or that that that.
So but unless you're talking about factorial function.
That's true. And then and then we'll actually that that'll come up later to, say, the factory of function.
There's a mathematical notation that has a that has it in it.
And then that's part of the formula. So if you give it the sentence ends with fact in factorial, then you say in factorial,
period, unless it's a surprising sentence, which were in fact sorry, a factorial.
That's that. That means something else. Yeah.
OK. So then I'm actually then Bob also kept another thing on, on his copy of the other thing, which is a letter that I sent in the next April.
You can't. Congratulations to you and the Dean for his decision.
I hope you will. Acceptance. I think you'll be accomplish great things for our department. Please be our chairman.
Sincerely, Don. P.S. If I were allowed to use an exclamation points, I would be more emphatic.
OK. Next thing I wanted to show you is a fact.
That's what I want to spend this week on is is editing, edit, editing drafts and process that things go through.
And so I thought, why not take the notes I just got from Tracey on Fridays class and and should show
you what's going to happen between now and the time you get the next handout,
which comes on Wednesday. OK. So. So I got this. So I got this in the mail this morning.
In fact it's they, it's the, it says ten, fifty four a.m. is when I get guess maybe when I e-mail it to Phyllis.
When did she mail it to me. Two forty seven oh oh Tracy.
It's really an honor that you got up early for this class. OK, so now.
So anyway so.
So, so I'm getting you some computer mail and then I'm and then I'm passing it to my secretary to put it in the tech form and everything.
And so these are this is the scribbling that I get that I gave to my secretary to type from.
And Phyllis Will also has the hardcopy so that she can I mean, she has the electronic form of the other things so that she can she can do this.
And so then she you know, these notes all look as if it's really her seeing everything.
But then I get to go straight, you know,
I get to correct myself when I said something I didn't mean to or where and when I can really improve something,
make it make, you know, a little better than the truth. I don't mind doing that.
So I. So I. I added a sentence here about the here she's talking about different kinds of things that are acceptable.
It's term papers and I added user manuals or parts thereof and things like that, anything that falls into a etc. etc. now and then.
So she's going through this this this transcript here and then basically I'm experimenting now.
How to when do when do I want to use single quotes? When do I want to use double quotes?
And I haven't quite converged on the solution, but I think single, I think when we're talking about parts of sentences.
Sometimes it's wise to have a distinction, but I haven't. But maybe that's going to be more confusing to a reader than they're not.
Or I don't know. But I think I'm gonna I'm gonna try now to to use double quotes for things that were said which were recording what somebody said.
What single? Cause we're recording something, some piece of text as written.
So we're playing with that. And and so anyway, I first I went through this.
This panned out and I told Charlotte I was gonna give her a nice macro for this relation here so that
it would so that she just had to type backslash less then and so on to get to get that come out.
Nice. And. And she's. And Tracy has introduced a very nice innovation here.
And she's going to replace a specific formula with something in brackets that will indicate what sort of the generality of the of the of the topic.
And OK, I added a sentence here.
Some papers have more columns and periods. That was just to make a point that that didn't come out OK.
So I went through and edited that. And. And then I.
And then I got Phyllis's output looks looks like this.
And then I wrote down once I saw a typewritten. All of a sudden I saw a lot of other things that I didn't see in.
In the mean I mean, this type typeset rather than typewriter style.
And when things when they look typeset didn't look you know, I wanted to make more changes as I saw this as I saw this draft.
In fact, I guess Winston Churchill and Herbert Hoover, when you got to be that powerful in the thirties,
that they would never look at anything that was done by a typewriter. But they had they had somebody actually would typeset it first in the drafts
of their speeches and they would read it and type for it and gave it back.
And when Hoover dieting, he he he was over 80 years old and had eight secretaries working for it.
And that's like. So anyway, here I when I reread this after it was typed and I and I decided that handout number four didn't look right there,
but it'd be better if I said no for something like this then. Here was the title of handout number four, had a period in it,
but I decided to take the period out when I'm quoting it looked a little confusing over a period.
The middle sentence there. Here it's in the interests of succinct notes and it looked to me better interest of the notes.
But now here's what here's a more specific thing. I have replaced many literal phrases with their generic equivalents.
Now, to me,
it's better to say you replace something by and I don't know why I and I didn't have my my my favorite dictionary and things like that is at home.
And so I'm not sure what the what the usage panel would recommend on this.
But but to me, replacing something by something else is a little bit better than with something else.
I don't know. And I can look it up later. But right now I decided to to replace it by the generic equivalents.
And now and I'm putting a cork around relation it looks seem to look a little better.
It would look little naked without it.
So it's gonna say now, for example, I might have replaced, quote, A greater than B by, quote, relation in Britain in angle brackets, unquote, period.
Now, here I took out a comma that was in front of that because, you know, it would come and interferes with the fact that you're replacing X by Y.
Now, again, I took out a comma here while the colon in comma defined as follows is fine, comma No.
One. I put this in single quotes. I'm talking about defining as follows as a part of a as a part of a sentence.
And that's something that I'm really quoting, but sort of a piece of text that I'm talking about as a piece of text.
Well, a colon in this piece of text is fine, comma. It seems to make more sense to do it that way.
But when you're talking about talking up, let's not have a draft load that gives you a thick white spaces between the lines making corrections.
Oh, yes, it does. Right. But I didn't tell Phyllis to do that.
Yeah, that's right. I could have used some kind of a double spacing feature so that there would be more room here.
Yeah. It's confusing. And actually, I think Phyllis sometimes brings a magnifying glass to work in order to in order to find this.
Yeah. So good point. In fact, now that's another thing.
No, Mike. My publisher wants me when I finish this book to send them a double spaced.
Copy of the chapter. But one of the one of the things that's important to the exposition is what faces what on what pages.
And so I can't do that without without sort of hiding the other aspect of it, which is how the pages look.
So maybe I give them both credit on very long page paper.
Yeah, we have that 17 inch paper now and we can. I could try that.
OK. Yeah. And then I add a few like here at the very bottom I just added another set of the outer parenthesis altogether.
Now this is a sentence of mine. I, I changed what Terry report is remembered about what I said on Friday because I didn't remember it the same way.
So, so. So this last part is my own, my own sense of change.
I'm correcting that here because in some cases your audience may expect nested
parenthesis in this case or in any other when you feel you must have them.
I put in the word case there. I wrote it seemed better to me this time around.
But here we've already used the word case twice and it's still I felt it was OK in any other case
where you feel you must have them to the other CRB changed two brackets or curly braces and so on.
And this is the these are the notes for the for the previous time. Now, here's something now.
I mean, most of these things that I did then when I marked up Trace's original was was actually just to change the history
of of what what actually went on on Friday and improve it to what I thought I should have said and so on.
But here isn't the issue. You mentioned Helmet may have been the fellow to initiate something and and it just shows that I don't I mumble too much.
I'm sorry about that. Please don't applaud that.
And how much the pyro. How much the man who who also wrote how I write mathematics and things like that, I think he's the he's the initiator of this.
So I respect his name. And now here was one thing, though, where I write where I was technical point when Tracy wrote.
We can't read it very well here. It says when using a arrays as tea and phrases such as the first first component, she wrote.
Be careful about the font used. Now, that's that's fine.
But that's not very common. You'll find that in manuals and papers all the time somewhere.
I always say be careful, but you never tell you which way they have in mind.
It's obvious to them, which is the right way.
But but it's better to say to put two actually actually risk seeing which one is right and which one is wrong.
In fact, that's one of the characteristics I that's that I find is about my own writing style.
I tend to I tend to take risks.
I have a chance of making more than one hundred mistakes on every page because of the way I write thing.
I mean, I tend to give concrete examples and facts and things that can be right or wrong.
Instead of instead of talking around this subject, which which which is much less risky, and you can you can say a lot of things.
I mean, anybody who writes letters of recommendation knows all about how you can be more or less specific.
And and. But in my books, I try to I try to be specific,
something that that and that can actually be right or wrong so that a person can actually check it later on.
And and that means that if I have a hundred chances on every page to be right or wrong and if my if if
my average cumulative average on taking tests through college was I was only ninety seven percent.
That means I have three hours per page. Maybe something like that.
And so I have a chance of making, making errors that way.
But I think it's better to take that chance when you're writing, when you're writing something that people want to are gonna be using for reference.
OK, so then. So I added the example to set it in Roman.
And then I also had another phrase that Phyllis missed because my handwriting was so sloppy.
But I wanted to point out that the reason that it's better to put it in Roman is so that it doesn't confuse with being one to the S-T power,
which would be an Italian. OK, now let's see.
Is there any other comments here? Oh, I don't know.
Here's this is remember to capitalize. I want to look at the monitor and read it.
Remember the capitalized words like Thiermann Lemma in titles like in titles such as Lemmer one and Theorem two?
It seems to me here was an example of parallelism where we could improve words like Thiermann and titles like It would be better.
It was better to not to vary the choice of words in there.
Here. Oh, I don't know.
This must have been a typo, Tracy. But she said avoid past.
Boys, my temptation to write passive voice is bad was overwhelming.
For example, she says, right, it can be shown rather than approve shows.
So here she's recommending to write passive voice instead of I think maybe she was giving an example of using passive voice.
But I changed it to replace this by proof shows anyway.
And again, by instead of which does not.
And you see here one especially easy to read proof I decided to hyphenate.
This is to make it clear that the compound a.
And it's an easy to read proof rather than I mean something can be easy to read.
But but an easy to read proof.
And he does not seem to remember being told in high school that compound adjectives are hyphenated when they are before the noun.
But not when they are predicate adjectives. Is that is that right?
Yes. A proof is easy to read without hyphens and easy to read.
Proof is before the Nazi. But I had to walk or I mean,
I was writing random number generation a check on a random number generation and I and random number generators
and I and I point out that I sometimes hyphenated between random a number and when I took them all out,
just didn't look right at all. I think when it when it's automatically read as a unit anyway, you don't need to hide it.
But I didn't want somebody to think that I was checking a number generator at random, you know.
So it was generating random, but still it's better.
OK, well, now but I've been spending all this time, these last classes just criticizing everybody else's writing and so on here.
No, not one that I wanted to push to show that at least stuff that all of us in this room can can
can get some some some noticeable benefits by by changing the things that we do every day.
But I should also be now criticizing myself, too.
And so that's what I want to do the rest of today. And and also probably Wednesday, maybe even Friday,
by showing you what I was doing to my own writing a couple of weeks ago when I was when
I was working on the first draft of a chapter for this for actually see us to 60,
which meets Monday, Wednesday, Friday at nine o'clock.
And I've I finished five chapters of their of their text and they're still they're still going away at full speed.
And I have to try to given Chapter seven. I'm going to skip Chapter six for the time being so that I'm not in too much pressure.
I have a plan in my head, but I'm not going to actually put it through the computer so I don't fall too far behind.
A seven is a much more important chapter and it's sort of, you know,
the way things break in Chapter seven will also affect some of the sequence that I want to choose in the final Chapter six.
So. So anyway, I'm I'm spending day and night right now writing this book.
Meanwhile, teaching this course a little bit.
But any any deficiencies in this course are due to the fact that I'm reading I'm putting most of my time into the book.
But the book gives lots of of examples of of what we're talking about in this class.
So I kill two birds with one stone. And I want to show you now the different speed, you know, before and after of the manuscript of this book.
And the thing from before is the very first print.
This is the very first print I got out of the computer. I, I had typed quite a lot of pages for several days and didn't make any proofs.
And and then I decided I was going to get them all out and take it home and mark it up in
my comfortable chair at home and and decide with the way things the way things should do.
Now, this book is called Concrete Mathematics, and it's got three authors.
I'm I'm I'm on Patashnik who's sitting here and smiling in the front row and lends me his watch every day.
It is the man who did the hardest part of the work. He spent several years preparing a first draft of this book.
And then my turn came this summer to go through and make the near final draft and run run.
Graham and I, I did mentioned Ron. Ron is the third author.
He's taught the course twice and and he's at Bell Labs.
And we but we're he comes out quite a lot and we talk on the phone a lot and and and I've been discussing everything I do with him very closely.
And he sends me drafts, sections and things. So.
There's three of us working on this. And but but I I was you know, this is my.
My cycle of it that I want to show you here. And the book now, I went through several stages before it got this far.
And I guess I say. So we started out and Oren wrote the the the draft using the classic book style.
Then we sent to the publisher Shodan the the the idea. So we had for the for the book.
And they got a professional designer to send specs as to as to how the book ought to finally appear.
And this is an aspect of book.
These books that I should say something about that a lot of people don't don't realize the value of a good of a good book design.
And I was I've been very lucky with my publisher over the years to have somebody who who who who makes the decisions.
That might seem obvious as to how wide the cut the text is going to be,
what sizes and styles of type are going to be used and where and things like that.
Now, the strange thing that we wanted to use it have in this book wasn't was a new idea.
Well, it's not. It's I got it from start from Stanford Publications, but it's New Idea, a math book teaching to include graffiti in the book.
This is what we call graffiti, which means comments by the students to be included in the text, to be included in the printed book.
And these are the things that the students will typically read represents the kind
of remarks that smart people in the back row would say to each other during class.
It's the kind of thing like when when Marianne says, except when you're using factorial functions,
you know, when you talk about exclamation points, when we put that in the margin of the book.
If I was writing a book on technical writing, it would say something about exclamation points.
And in the graffiti, in the margin would say, except when you talk about factorial, you see and.
And this came from a wonderful book that Stanford has put out since fairly since at least 1970 call approaching Stanford.
And the I don't think they still have it this way. I'm not sure if they if they have it in a great old style that they're used to.
But there was the in the middle of their pages on that book. You always had the standard thing that you would expect to find from universities.
The book that goes out gets mailed to freshmen after they've accepted. And.
And it tells you about dormitories and and all kinds, things like this.
And then in the margins of this book are things that will tell what it really is.
And they'll say, like Stanford dorms are like zoos without keepers know.
They'll say that the student government is for megalomaniacs and all these very things.
So it's and it was it was different every year.
But they but they got real students to write real the real impression some of them were positive, some of them were negative.
But they all came through as being honest and not. And I thought, wouldn't it be need to have a math book that would do the same.
And so we're going try to do that with us with this. And so so the book designer took a look and said, you know what?
That sounds good,
but I'd like to put the graffiti instead of the way they did it in the Stanford publication in the outer margin when I put it in the inner margin.
And he just. And this sounded a little strange. But actually, I look I look at it.
I look at it in practice and it seems to work so. So this book, when you open it up, is going to have a nice wide pages.
There'll be a wide outer margin. But there will also be this inner side of the gutter of the book as you open it up here.
This intermarket is going to have little, little little comments and graffiti.
No,
there's not much graffiti original now because it's the job of the students who are now taking 260 to write the rights to write more of it on here.
This is some that's leftover from last year's notes that were that were put in.
So another thing a designer told me is he wanted to have, you know, very large numbers for the tech, for the chapter.
Highly wanted to be on here. He wanted. He wanted the first page of a check.
Every right hand page is supposed to usually have to have a certain size of numbers here.
But at the title page, the number is actually gonna go down here. I put this little mark here so that the person who's who's photographing these
sheets later on in the camera was going to line up this page in the proper place.
So this is a shadow of where the number ordinarily is because the cameramen usually has a little slot on this thing.
We'll put the put the thing in there so that'll help and line it up.
I put a copyright notice on all this because we're supposed to protect ourselves. Way anybody can rip us off.
When we when we reproduce something, as long as we say that is copyright, then we're protected.
I think as we understand a lot.
Another thing that book designer said is he'd like to start out every chapter with, you know, have this line that goes all the way across the page.
And he's going to have the. So at a certain space, before and after, after the subhead, he has this extra wide indentation,
but the very beginning, he starts out every paragraph with a word, with something in big letters.
Now, this actually imposes a restriction. There's some sentences.
Wouldn't work at all if you put the first things in big letters, like if I didn't have this, let's take a breather.
If it just said the previous chapters and that would be in, quote, in big letters, that wouldn't tell you anything about Chapter five.
It also says Chapter five is about the previous chapters. So I needed something I had to add add something to to to set the theme for the chapter end.
But the right theme that I wanted to set here was the fact that we're that we're that there's a change of pace coming along.
And. And so I say we're now we're going you know, the previous chapters have seen some heavy going and stuff.
Now we're going to study binomial coefficient would turn out to be a more important
in applications and be easier to manipulate than those other quantities.
And then I I'm writing in afterwards. This seems like a song, better to say, than all of the other quantities to me.
So I'm a little more informal. I wouldn't go as far as saying that all them other quantities.
But I can go this far and give and give a light flavor to I.
I'm trying to give the flavor of enjoying the material as well as what not.
But but anything that gets really bad puns or anything like that goes into the margin.
Lucky us. Take as you want.
There's an exclamation point. Yeah. Lucky see. I hear this.
Yeah. This is a this is a Yeah.
And explanation psychiatric factory.
All right. Okay. So the commas around that because they were easier to manipulate.
Or a more important apple and be easier to manipulate than all those other quantities.
I don't know, maybe, maybe to help pass it but I might.
But that's another thing is going to happen is that there's gonna go through copyediting after work, after we're done.
So we're going to have a professional copyeditor look at this. And.
And that's another important service provided by a publisher in these days of authors self publishing.
One must realize that even though, you know,
even those those of us who have written hundreds of thousands of words can still learn from from professionals.
And these things. So maybe you'd be better. We'll see. Turn out to be a more important and applications would be easier to manipulate
than all those other quantities it could take out there and be without that.
It was it was it was it was getting too complicated to me.
But we'll see now. Another thing is any any writing can be improved.
Any any anything complex in the world can be can be improved.
I mean, it's it's amazing to me to find out that Czajkowski was never happy with his symphonies.
Every time he heard that he wanted to make changes, you know. And finally,
you have to put something out the door and and the things that I know that various things that other people have done that I really that I really,
really love, I find out that they didn't like it at all. And. And the same with any large computer program.
A beautiful Vaisse or whatever. There's always if it's if it has it has enough complexity.
There's always some way in which it could be even better. That's sort of an axiom that nothing is is its optimum.
If it's complex. And so so I'm I'm sure that as I read this and as well as anyone else reads it, they'll find ways to improve it.
And and that's the danger I have of going through this because I never converges.
Every time I every time I read I can I can do something better.
Other things jump out at me that don't jump other times and depends on your mood and style of type, as we saw before, we're reading.
And and also, if there's a certain personal style that must come through, I should say something about style like forgot.
I forgot to say that before. It's that there's a wonderful there's a very nice comment about this.
I try to remember exactly how I said it about by Dijkstra when he was in his notes and structured programing many years ago,
where he was trying to talk about the question of style and programing.
And he said that the fact that having a style is very important, but he doesn't want to dictate a particular style.
He said the concept of style, a good teacher of music or something will.
A group of musical composition will teach the students how to develop their own style, but not how to mimic his his particular style.
But he has to have his style, which is which is definitely him. And.
And so, you know, we give a lot of rules saying it's better to do this and this and that might not be right for you.
It's just us. If you feel strongly about it, that's more important than if you then if you're following a rule,
you these rules are given mostly as guidance to one person's opinion, but your own style is going to be the thing that finally controls.
And like my my wife and I, when we write our Christmas newsletter every year, well,
we finally decided it was impossible for us to to to to say it was by both of us.
So we alternate paragraphs. I mean, there's no way that we can both write a paragraph that we both agree is in the proper style.
And so so there are things that that are definitely I can look at and say that sounds like me.
And I think that's it doesn't sound like me, although I like it anyway. Another question.
Yeah. Say those other qualities. There's no other in there that intentionally casual.
What. All of those. All of what I would know say all of those other quality.
All of the other qualities. Yeah. That's a very it's a very difficult to say when to put up after all.
And we're not to. And in this case, I would say, since I'm being informal,
I'm saying all those other guys intentionally being being a bit casual there sometimes all sometimes I put in of it,
you know, on a draft after the word all. And then the next draft to take it out again and flip flop.
It's not it's not an easy. It's not an easy call.
I think what the curse of sound was always tell you the right way you get
something right is you rewrite it and rewrite it and rewrite it and rewrite it.
Now, I'm curious just for you about how many drafts do you think you'll go through before something finally hits the shelf?
Know whatever you draft. OK. I'll show you Oren's original sometime, too.
That's coming up. But I wanted to criticize myself first in this in this thing.
But this is an order and went through several drafts and.
But now, typically right now, I'm I don't know.
I start out I always composed originally and in pencil.
And a lot of people find it better to compose at a terminal. I should say something about that.
It's it's that's something that I found works much better for me.
Even if I'm writing a letter to my mother or something, I can compose it better pencil.
And I can't then I can't get along a very good typist. I type faster than I think.
I used to where I went to secretarial school and I was in high school and I got I was typing 80 words a minute and stuff.
I learned different. I learned to kind of shorthand and all kind of stuff. But for me, that's not the issue.
When I'm writing the. It seems that that the the way the the timing in which I actually think of what
I'm going to say is is almost perfectly matched to my writing speed with pencil.
And so there's no synchronization problem. But if I try to type, I'm typing faster than I think.
And that and then I have to stop that. That distracts my thoughts.
And and so I don't I don't get a good result unless I get to to some some part of it which which is which is routine.
And I can then in my in my original pencil graph and I can just, you know,
write a sort of a scribble and say, you know, I'll fill this in ad lib, I can take that.
And as I go through the same things I can do. But this is true with writing computer programs and other stuff.
And as I said, letters home, everything. I find that my original I can always do better.
But that's a matter of my own personal timing, I think.
Now, then, like Nils Nilsson is going to is going to be one of the lecturers here.
I think [INAUDIBLE] kill dwell now.
But he he went through, I think, five or six drafts of his chapter on non monotonic reasoning because of because you want to get the exposition right.
And every time you and when you put yourself in the frame of mind of of of of big writing, the exposition for for someone who's learning the subject,
that's a it's very profitable because you have to think of things in a different way than you do when you're just doing research on the subject.
And and so these different drafts, when it went through, I had experience sets presenting several theory Metroid theory,
something right where I tore up many different ideas because every time I would get to a certain point, I would.
I would I would see that. Yeah, there was a much better way.
Tony Hawk was head of had a paper about communicating sequential processes or something like this.
And he I think he he completely revised those algorithms more than a dozen times over over a period of two years.
Now, those are more exceptional. I think typically I will I will mostly go through a rough.
Well, here I had Orrin's first draft and I think he went through several, several stages.
So I had a very good initial approximation to start with. But I'll typically put something down and then and then something will click.
That'll that'll be a unifying principle that allows me to go back and rewrite and rewrite it from that.
From that point of view. And then after I have my pencil draft, then I edited for flow as I'm typing it in and then I get it.
And then I get a piece like this and that's it. And then I go through and edit that and then I and then we'll see what happens to that.
And then as I say, copy it. It goes through. But you see things in different in different ways on these different different passes.
Part of it. When you're writing. I know many computer programs that were that were greatly improved by the fact that
they scrapped everything after six months of work and started over completely.
In fact, in one case, they suspect it was their boss who came in at night and destroyed all their notes and flowcharts and everything.
The boss was Bob Barton at the time. Anybody knows the history and.
This was at Burls. The problem is the best compiler has ever written was the ALGOL compiler written at Burrowes about 1960.
And everybody came to work after after. They've been working hard on this for many months.
And and the whole thing was was was lost. They never did find it again.
But they they play in a month. They had read they had gotten back to where they were and they were much happier too.
With what? With what came up. I'm not about to throw this away, though.
I've got more now an hour.
Now, among the among the things that I find this draft, of course, I typed are typos.
And I hope I caught most of them non Nagui, even integers and so on.
My my terminal tends to drop letters when FCP is going on at the same time.
And so so there'll be a lot of mis misled.
Now it says the binomial coefficient has many uses.
Beside it is combinatorial replication. So we remove some of the restrictions here.
I check. Are you starting to use Future Tense? We will remove some of the restrictions and then I go back to Present Tense.
It's most useful, it turns out, to allow an arbitrary real income chording or in you're pretty well,
I think you'll recognize this as this as his as his language here, the spark.
And and so we give the definition of binomial coefficients.
And here I hear it. Here I put a space in here.
Now, here is something that I'm not supposed to have to do. But it turns out that this R has a has a big dot just matching the dot in the semicolon.
And so I'm not above going into them and saying insert a very thin space between those two symbols just so long.
So it won't be distracting to a reader. And it says this emphasizes that binomial coefficients makes sense when any real number appears in the end.
Well. Well, look what I put in here. This emphasizes the fact that binomial coefficients make sense in any real number.
Creary. This is that I did I really leave that that way after I got after here.
And yeah, it's on.
You'd looks better to me. I will. Now, maybe the copy won't like that, but there we go.
Put that in now. Here it says there's no common thread to replace Gilbert.
Ari. Ari. Because minus one turns out to be as important. Special case.
The non-negative index R equals one half also turns out to be useful.
Here I, I didn't I decide to change the minus one after not to be much more useful and I didn't want to it didn't read write to me
at speed so I changed to oh not a non integer index like R equals negative a half instead of the non negative in index.
So that can be done. And it's mostly because when I'm reading it at speed it I'm getting it looked like
they know the regional sense was only I was only referring to one or two cases. I want to make them up, make the thing a little more general on.
And so I decided to do this. A reasonable definition is possible, but actual applications are comparatively rare.
I. I think that I messed it up when I edited something and wrote there and fight and it's not.
It sounds better not to be to be to use actually a passive, passive construction there.
A reasonable definition can be given, but actual applications are comparatively rare. I think I would do that.
OK. Now, let's see anything new here.
Before getting to the identities that we will use to team binomial coefficients,
let's take a peek at some small values in table five point one that wasn't necessary to save some.
Let's take a peek at some small values. I was just gonna put a comma in there.
Then I just leave out the whole you just say, let's take a peek at some small values and here they are.
Then I say the numbers in table 5.1 form the beginning of Pascal's Triangle named after Blaise Pascal.
Without a plan throughout the comma here, it may not replace Pascal because he wrote so on.
It seemed better. And then I have this table in Peire so we can see the numbers of Pascal's triangle.
And I said, put another extra little bit of space in there.
You know, jazz it up here. I have some bad typos.
Oh, here. Here's an interesting zeroes I have with a special typeface in this book.
The book is is actually a book that that sort of the spirit of the book is imbued by the wonderful mathematician Leonard Euler of the 18th century.
And and a typeface was commissioned by the American society called Euler.
And it was it was designed by Herman SOF, probably the greatest typeface designer in the world.
And it's never so far been used in mathematical texts.
However, it needed some tuning up because first for the spacing and so on.
And I had been promising to do that for years while. Again, killing two birds with one stone.
I realized that here's a book that I knew I could use the oilor typeface and I could see it in many,
many different applications, different kinds of mathematics. And only that was very appropriate because the whole book is about Euler's work.
And so I decided that this book will be the one that launches the the other typeface.
And I'm making experiments with o with it as I go seeing it in lots of formulas.
And then in order to in order to go with this typeface, it tends to be a little bolder than another idea of the face.
By the way, is it supposed to look a bit handwritten or something like a mathematician who had who had a nice penmanship would actually do?
And he was doing his nice math, his mathematics. He was presenting it.
And one of the things that that I've noticed is that when people actually write it a zero, it never really closes perfectly at the top.
But that tends to have a point there when it comes together.
So the zero in either if you can we see that on the screen, you see the zero has a bit of a point at the top anyway,
but all the not numerals in oilor are different from the numerals in my ordinary based text font.
And so I have to just think I could put this zero in dollar signs.
And so I think I could get it as in the mathematics font when I'm talking about zero.
The plural of a symbol is it is something we'll be talking about later in the course.
Some people would write zeros without the prosperously and some people would put the apostrophe in.
And when we have a phrase like the the when we talk about the 70s, it's it's a convention that came in in the 60s to drop the apostrophe.
I know when I think of the convention came in in the 70s,
but it's now considered correct when you refer to the 70s to say seven zero S. instead of seven zero apostrophe s.
But when you're talking about A's and B's in a formula, I think you're minding your P's and Q's.
You put the apostrophes in there. And when you talk about zeros and ones right now,
most most journals will put the apostrophe in accepted I Tripoli trends transactions on information theory,
where 99 percent of their papers are about zeros and ones and they're used to putting it without the apostrophe and zeros on.
In this case, I'm but I'm I'm putting apostrophe in there, but I'm saying that VMT entries are actually zeroes because of a zero in the numerator.
And then I have a typo here. And then I give an example. Well,
the thing I wanted to get out here is that that went that if your typeface for four
numbers is the same as the typeface that you're using for a date like like sixteen,
twenty three, and you don't have to put that, then you don't have to put the zero in dollar signs if it's a formula.
But in this book, when I'm referring to something that's that's part of a mathematical zero rather than the number zero in my in my text,
then I'm going to have to I have to make that distinction.
So that's one of the the difficulties, I suppose, of working with oilor in a book, although it made my my actual manuscript look more more logical.
These entry are empty simply to help emphasize the rest of the table.
And here I put in a passage past perfect. These entries have been left blank simply to help emphasize the rest of the table.
Seemed to me to read better that way. OK, now let's see.
What are we doing here? Here's something I had trouble with.
And then I went and I changed it more. I'm sure after after we start if I kept typing O.
K. all the others. Pheto here historical remark, I guess.
But binomial coefficients are not really being due to Pascal.
If it interrupted the flow of the paragraph two to say too much about Pascal in this paragraph,
when I'm when we're really trying to get people into the idea of the numbers.
But I didn't want to give the idea that Pascal invented binomial coefficients.
And I have this outlet chancer once in a while to write my own little piece of graffiti.
So some of these are ghostwritten by the author. Most of them are going to be due to this to the students.
That's right. And I'll try to. And I'll try to jazz it up a little bit to make it seem more student like if I like.
Now I'm trying to. Now, in this book, people are getting the pattern one, three, six, 10, 15, 20, one and so on is occurring.
And so people will pick some of the readers who have read the previous chapters.
Might that might jump out at them as a pattern.
And I would and I'm trying to I'm trying to save say that somehow that triangular numbers are conspicuously present in Pascal's triangle.
And I wanted to say, which column are they present in? And the story subscript is two here.
And so I'm talking about N plus one. Sub two is the formula.
We had four triangular numbers. I'm trying to, you know, as I'm trying to as we're introducing a new subject,
I'm trying to tie in with things that we've that we already know from previous chapters.
But now I have a problem. I want to refer to this to this column here, but I can't refer to it as the second column.
And the third column doesn't sound like the one four four inches two.
So but if I call column two, it just doesn't look it doesn't seem right because this is,
you know, because we just don't talk about column zero very often. And so I wanted to say the appropriate column here.
I hear it now. I change it to and over two columns.
But what did I finally end up with?
Yeah. I finally wound up with a typo in the in our two column table one.
I forget to put the word in there. That's terrible. I.
Oh, well. So anyway, you're seeing work in progress here also is a hard work place and and the words like,
oh yeah, I said all this is putting also is a very it's a very tricky word.
And I. And here I decided to really say it's also instead of also it's this particular thing.
And no, I didn't it it here.
This this. This is the last point I'll make today. This this. This sentence here sounded good to me when I when I.
When I wrote it longhand.
But it didn't sound it didn't didn't read good when I came in and it said there will be good reason to suspect that binomial coefficients lurk nearby.
And it didn't. And I thought it would be better here to say you will have a clue that binomial coefficients probably lurk nearby.
I was hedging a little bit, but then I changed it fine to we will have a clue that binomial coefficients probability lurk
nearby because finally it didn't look good to be talking about you all of a sudden here.
So that that was a change of style where we had a we had our coöperative dialog.
OK, what you can do, you can bet it.
Yeah. OK. Well, so I'll show you some other aspects of this on Wednesday.
My reading of these newspaper.